it's one thing to make the money but
it's another thing to be smart with the
money uh where do the ideas come from to
start these businesses I mean like for
you to go and do the line I remember
when there was conversation about your
line and your line being available in
Kmart which I thought was genius right I
was like holy to understand how big
the world is to understand that Middle
America is the best part of America
because those are the most people like
responding what was it that made you say
I want to go in this direction and this
is what I'm going to focus on well you
know what that was even way before
modern families okay so in the Latin
Market I you know I had my job at
Univision but you know at that time in
the 90s you mean you were I was making
money but it wasn't really like you know
like Mansion money or Corvette money you
know no it was uh you know money to
survive and to you know save for my
son's college education and all that it
was okay but I always wanted to I always
wanted more you know I always wanted to
create something thing for me for my son
for my family you know I went from
Colombia for a lot of problems to living
in the United States I wanted to take
care of all of them so I wanted to make
money I love money
okay and then so I that I started making
calendars the only thing that I could
sell was really myself okay you know at
that time because I was young and fresh
I started doing like uh calendars you
know like like January February all that
well dude I'm sorry January due January
again January February it's the same
poll is just right to left you didn't
really change yes so one of those and I
did really good okay the calendars ended
up being a big success yeah it would be
success and so I started realizing you
know I am I am the product and I can
sell you know
myself it does it sounds horrible no it
doesn't you talk about like you're
talking about your likeness yes and at
the end of the day realizing your words
and realizing the value in your likeness
sometimes it was overlooked by a lot of
people in the business so you're
catching this is dope as hell so what
started out as calendars then became
became more and more stopped because for
example I knew that to be able also I I
always had a very good chemistry with
girls like you know with girl women's
fans and they would always since I'm
young come to me when they would meet me
for a picture or something it's like oh
what perfume are you wearing oh with
what do you wash your hair oh with what
is that lipstick oh where is this outfit
and so it oh it's always the world
always asking me so I'm like that's why
I always wanted to create all this like
I mean I wanted to be like I mean I wish
I was like some kind of like Martha
Steward of the Latin or you know it's
like you always like always my idea my
dream I mean I cannot even compare but
you but you but you are like you granted
Martha's success is her success but
you're talking about somebody that's
really thriving in the business of
Commerce like creating products selling
product
um and successfully selling more product
and constantly building well you are so
you don't have to say like I want to try
I think that's the dopest thing about
your your road to Monumental success is
that it compounded past the actress and
you know acting isn't going to get us to
the crazy place of wealth that's one
tier it's tapping into the things that
you that you've done and that you did
well well but for example you know I
think now when I started well Modern
Family finished three years ago and I
did it for 11 years so I mean 14 years
ago that not as many actresses had you
know other businesses they were just
actors as you know you could see one or
two selling something but it was not you
know like that and because I was coming
from the Latin Market and when I got the
film with murder with Modern Family
I mean I knew I could you know be an a
person for commercials for example and
then you know
you when I thought that I could bring to
the table to someone was for example if
you hire me
you in one day of shooting you get it in
Spanish
you get it in English yes okay
why hire Kevin Hart that can only speak
English when you can hire Sofia Regatta
in one day it's happening Sophia 20 in
Spanish and in English yeah so you know
but you understand well I do but I don't
feel like you have to use me as an
example of what not to hire you here who
else am I going to use well I clearly
speak both languages yeah so that's the
one mistake that you've made we don't
have to get into that